Savannah Jaz now cider finds the open man the
save by Deco on the shot by Panera paner back
to Fox long shot save Deno there's a rebound
and that's fired into the crease and cleared
out Carson Susi cleared it out of the
crease saan that was a pass and he score
F srock it's a power play Go the Rangers again
this is this unselfishness throw it around wait
prer will be all alone in front and B sees
him that's what get you started now there's
chaos c those back to the net Susi takes it
out now they throw it back thater loses his
stick he's not sure which way to go go he has
really gotten his scoring touch back he went
through some really difficult times his father
was sick for a long time and eventually passed
away in front they score it's JT Miller the man
who leads them in scoring set up in front point
when he releases that is tough to stop five games
against jurkin so here's besser who throws it in
Pon will get it Quick Pass quick shot tie
game oh man that quickly they just move it
so fast and there's a quick release from JT
Miller CH moves it when Hughes circles back
with tro checking him Sam LY number 18 put
it in front of the St they score hoglander
heels hoglander set up pin front and there's
that quickness and the speed that you talked
about Joe the quick transition and Vancouver
takes it two to one lead he'll Circle back
now the Rangers have players back but you got
to pick somebody up and just that you know the
you know You' got enough players back in in
in the action but as soon as you as ever sa
before Luger on the four check Ines ble to
move it up and Aaron sends it on goal troch
and a r Direction a save by Demco what a
save on Panera's redirection Snider shot
save Demco bats the pucked into the corner
he can skate and he can play and he's done a
good job nice play on the takeaway by trouba
trouba tried to get it to coie a backit save
another save by Deco on VC played by Fox Aon
finds Lind Gren a minute and a half to go in
the first period walk for yeah a re Direction
by Chek and a save by Demco the Rangers look
to change lren lifts it out of the Zone 20
seconds to go on the period lead for pson
that's their go to the net and you he scores
what a give and go B and pson and it's 31
Vancouver he's done a great wrist shot goes to
his backand here beautiful little
pass and besser just went through
everybody no one picked him
up going through the middle
and then he does the rest of the work himself
ra forier the shot by TR sa to rebound stop by
Deco Tyler Myers little move and a shot block
didn't get through rder fires it across
Sloter knocked it down with a glove save
shurkin had to make a tough one with the
blocker the right arm a cave on that shot
Fox with it oh another dangerous passers have
to be careful Panera inde deep for the first
save Deo on tro great pass from Panera to tro
now JT Miller desser and it's taken away by
L Sor off with him is p this SC
oh that shot a beauty by our T paner and it
cuts the Vancouver lead to three to2 play by
loer right here we at a stick quick stick steals
the puck now gets the blue and has to wait wait
wait finds the hottest scorer on the team and one
of the hot scores in the league and paner does
it so lerer makes the defensive play and in this
play Under Pressure and there's that shot by tamy
paner good job by trouba coming over and troch
staying with Miller the good friends opposite one
another trouble with a hit Pon moves ins sa
rebound put in by Pon oh man what hands and
the Canucks regain the two-goal lead it's
4-2 and maybe even the second but there's
the outlet pass and little give and go and then
as Miller goes down to block it she this is just
some kind of a goal by pon pon just Waits and
that's a lot of length you have to wait and be
patient with as Miller went down he just takes
his time gets his own rebound and then has the
fabulous hands to score that was broken up
by kie Gust in the outlet to benino that's
stopped at the line the KN come right back
you sud nice pass behind the back hoglander
oh man look at that goal Neils hoglander
makes it five to2 he went behind the back
and they and they get going here's a pass
that gets picked off that was Bonino that
try to make a cross- siiz pass to get picked
off PW Suter is able to get it to H hoglander
and Drew the legs and then through the legs
oh man through his legs and through sherin's
legs nice little pass and in bler shot
stopped by shurin buffier heads up
ice nice feed tro and he
scores and the garden comes to life V sent tro
with his second of the game cuts the Vancouver
lead to 5 to three and Steve was saying that's
what they need to do how about this play by lrer
look at this little pass backhand pass over a
stick and then there's a similar shot only on
the other side of the ice that panan had scored on
nice little pass and then up high with Tempo going
down the top of the net open there's Fox with a
shot saved him Co the rebound went wide started
with a faceof win by tro the ducks come out
with it besser patteron into the empty net bull
side and that puts it away for the Vancouver
Canucks pon as the initial shot by Fox was
stopped with the right pad and then Myers is
strong here on the board just gets it up the
boards and best are able to find Pon for
the easy one and the clock ticks off and
the Vancouver connects and the Rangers split
the season series Rangers one in Vancouver 4
to3 in overtime this one Thatcher Demco
is 3 and0 lifetime against the Rangers